As an alternative to any of these approaches for
giving patients the data from their AHR records,
why not give them direct access to those records?
Dr. Schenck and Warner first proposed
this radical idea in the 1973 New England Journal of Medicine.
In 2010, Beth Israel Deaconess Medical Center, in Boston,
Geisinger Health System in rural Pennsylvania,
and Seattle's Harborview Medical Center,
launched an exploratory study of the idea,
funded by the Robert Wood Johnson Foundation.
Primary care doctors invited their patients to
read their notes via secure online portals.
The results were published in 2012,
in the prestigious journal Annals of Internal Medicine.
According to this effort, now called OpenNotes,
the big takeaways were,
doctors reported little change in their workload.
Patients overwhelmingly approve of note sharing.
Few patients are worried or confused by their notes.
Today five million patients have access to OpenNotes.
You can visit https://www.opennotes.org for more information.
But we will now watch two videos provided by OpenNotes.
The first, shows how patients report reading
their notes helps them feel more in control of their health and health care.
This second video provides evidence that patients can
provide quality control from their own notes.